ils n'ont pas eu autant d'activités qui
avait espéré quoi il y a quelques mois
cette propriété se serait vendu en un
clin d'oeil une maison unifamiliale dans
l'ouest de toronto pour moins de 3
millions de dollars les acheteurs s'y
seraient bousculés mais aujourd'hui la
situation est différente
c'était pas rare de voir 40 visites pour
un week-end là si on a dix visites
baisser un peu plus la norme quoi une
baisse d'activité que cet agent
immobilier attributs directement à la
hausse des taux d'intérêt la capacité
d'emprunt des ménages à cause de
l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt a
abaissé d'environ 25% on parle d'un
marché qui était absolument à surchauffe
un marché qui commence
rien justement nécessaire croit cet
économiste mais on commence à voir aussi
les
leurs ou vient d'acheter une nouvelle
maison elle fait partie de ceux qui ont
profité de ce renversement de vapeur le
prime est très bon un achat arabe et qui
fait en sorte que l'avocate ne
s'inquiète pas trop de la hausse des
taux d'intérêt si le coût de la vie en
général qui la préoccupe on peut trouver
des façons de de compenser pour le 400 $
le 1000 $ de plus qu'on paie en
hypothèques par mois peut être
potentiellement parce qu'on dit ok s'ils
aiment bien assez longtemps dans ma
jeunesse je vais revenir avec ray mais
manger en forme on mange trop fort par
jour
c'est ce qui est inquiétant
jim a aussi acheté une nouvelle maison
pendant la pandémie celle ci je les
trouvais n'était pas sur le marché
l'agente immobilière a choisi une
hypothèque à taux variable
j'ai choisi d'avoir un faux variable ou
mes remboursements votre les mêmes
chaque semaine mais je verrai la
différence à la fin du terme s'il lui
faudra un peu plus de temps pour
rembourser son prêt gemma crois quand
même avoir fait une bonne affaire si
vous regardez à aux années 80 par
exemple où on était dans les plus de 10
% plus de 12 % de taux d'intérêt
aujourd'hui on n'a encore vraiment
vraiment très bas donc il faut vraiment
relativiser et aux acheteurs jemal lance
ce message pense vraiment que c'est le
moment d'acheter
c'est encore inabordable rétorque eric
lombard dit un défenseur du droit au
logement les prix une bourde descendre
dit-il le marché reste complètement
inaccessible surtout pour les jeunes
voilà qui pour fuir une baisse c'est
notre homme
car même avec un marché qui refroidit la
réalité reste la même un manque de
logements et une population qui
explosent pour beaucoup de torontois
l'accès à la propriété reste donc un
rêve lointain et ce peu importe le taux
directeur ici à sainte-thérèse au canada
toronto